[Musica]
il sogno di essere un personaggio
letterario
non so se capita anche a voi una
signorina settecentesca uscita fuori
dalla commedia di goldoni per esempio
tutta elegante con il suo abito comprato
a credito
lei vuole impressionare un potenziale
marito se possibile danaroso e non
troppo spilorcio così poi potrà ripagare
il sarto per la borghesia veneziana del
settecento apparire è un lavoro a tempo
pieno
serve a posizionarsi nella catena del
valore in una società in cui l'accesso
al capitale viene prelevato fuori dalla
scena attraverso il circuito commerciale
dei mercanti della serenissima e sparsi
per il mondo intero è un flusso che va
dalla periferia al centro
ma non è un po la stessa cosa per noi
anche per la classe media occidentale si
tratta in qualche modo di riuscire a
posizionarsi nel punto più vantaggioso
lì dove un'ora del mio lavoro nel
terziario avanzato
magari nella cultura ne comanda due
cinque o dieci di qualcun altro
nel settore primario o secondario
io come potete vedere non ho nessuna
donna
in compenso un passato un bel po di anni
a studiare all'università
ovviamente con il sostegno economico
della mia famiglia
come tanti altri figli della classe
media
poi mi sono diciamo avvolto nel mio
titolo di studio no con i suoi bei pizzi
e merletti e anch'io ho cercato di
impressionare qualcuno un professore
universitario o magari che mi
indirizzasse verso la carriera
accademica
oppure un datore di lavoro che mi
proponesse un mestiere all'altezza delle
mie competenze
niente mi sono accorto come molti altri
della mia generazione che il nostro
investimento formativo non ha sortito
l'effetto sperato
forse non sono bravo abbastanza mi sono
detto o forse semplicemente non c'era
posto per tutti
e guardate che non vale soltanto per chi
come me si è laureato in materie
umanistiche
ma pure avvocati architetti persino gli
ingegneri oggi devono fare i conti con i
lavoretti precari e sottopagati e così
io sono partito dall'italia dicendo a me
stesso che in fondo tutta la cultura che
avevo accumulato e là senza dubbio un
bene e che mi aveva reso migliore mentre
la verità è che sfortunatamente mi aveva
reso insoddisfatto era costata molto e
mi andava fatto perdere delle occasioni
migliori
in compenso viene fornito un sacco di
esempi letterari in cui specchiarmi la
mia educazione mi hanno voluto in molti
sensi
lo scrive france kafka nei suoi diari e
poi nel racconto la metamorfosi si mette
in scena sotto forma di un gigantesco
scarafaggio odiato incompreso perché la
cultura è contemporaneamente un
privilegio è una condanna privilegio
perché la può accumulare soltanto chi
può permettersi di farlo e se il welfare
pubblico finanzia top anni di scuola
potok borse universitarie la ricchezza
privata trovera sempre un modo per
scavalcare non ha le risorse per
proseguire ma la cultura è anche una
condanna perché produce una sorta di
assuefazione un fascio di bisogno di
abitudini di mancanze
perché in fondo il fatto che ci sia
posto in certi settori fatto che non ci
sia posto non implica che non ci sia
posto in assoluto il difficile semmai è
accettare di fare qualcos'altro
rispetto a quello che siamo stati
educati a fare il difficile voglio dire
e riconoscere se stessi
ciò che facciamo nella nostra vita
quante volte abbiamo detto oppure
sentito io a fare il commesso
call center non ci vado però fateci caso
questi sono dei giudizi di classe il
problema che l'identità di classe in
fondo è molto più radicata di quanto
sembri quella che vi ho descritto la
condizione di quella che io chiamo la
classe disagiata cioè noi siamo i figli
di una classe che fu relativamente
agiata ovvero che ha potuto investire
delle risorse nell'inserimento
professionale e che oggi crolla sotto il
peso delle sue aspirazioni una classe
che non potendo accettare che non c'è
più posto per tutti che non c'è più
posto per lei in quanto classe reagisce
in maniera disordinata e auto
distruttiva per esempio ingolfando dei
settori professionali ormai saturi e
così danneggiandoli ulteriormente basta
osservare il numero esorbitante di
laureati in lettere in italia ricordate
parlavamo no centro in periferia perché
tutti si accalcano verso il centro
spinti dalle inclinazioni determinate
dalla propria classe di provenienza nel
giardino dei ciliegi cechov racconta le
vicissitudini malinconiche di una
famiglia costretta il nome
dell'inesorabile ragione economica a
vendere il suo bene più prezioso un
rigoglioso giardino menzionato persino
nel dizionario enciclopedico figuratevi
e questo è contemporaneamente comico e
tragico perché questo attaccamento dei
personaggi sembra uno sguardo esterno
come un lusso ma per loro è
incredibilmente prezioso perché non è
vero che i nostri bisogni
seguono una gerarchia che comincia dalla
soddisfazione di bisogni materiali a
quelli spirituali culturali simbolici
come credevano gli psicologi una volta
vedete questa è la piramide di maslow
modello che data dagli anni quaranta e
descrivere appunto la gerarchia dei
bisogni ma sulla base c'era
alimentazione poi l'auto sussistenza la
sicurezza e soltanto in seguito vengono
vengono appaiono i bisogni secondari
quindi il riconoscimento
l'autorealizzazione la stima la cultura
il nostro giardino dei ciliegi
ma come vi diranno tutti i sociologi del
consumo degli ultimi 50 anni
non funziona così non funziona come dove
credeva maslow prima viene il giardino
dei ciliegi
come potete vedere poi tutto il resto
ed è per questo che ci roviniamo insomma
come in molti cominciano a capire la
famosa piramide dei bisogni andrebbe
forse rovesciata per cominciare proprio
dal più futile io ad esempio volevo
scrivere un libro ci tenevo
assolutamente non so perché forse
appunto perché amo delle determinazioni
sociale culturale e poi l'ho fatto e ora
ve ne parla vi parlo delle tesi che che
vi ho scritto e che parlano un po di
tutto questo si chiama teoria appunto
della classe disagiata
ma se vi parlo di goldoni di kafka di
cechov non è soltanto perché questi
autori avevano descritto la crisi
esistenziale per chi vive ogni individuo
nel momento in cui deve fare i conti con
la realtà
se cito tutto questo forse lo avrete
capito e per farvi vedere con studiato
per fare la ruota con la mia gonna di
pizzo la cultura è come ci insegna la
sociologia un consumo vistoso una forma
di esibizionismo che ha una funzione
precisamente posizionale mostra dove
siamo dove vorremmo essere nella società
proprio come la donna della signorina
nel teatro di goldoni
per questo è così importante per questo
spesso diamo più importanza ai bisogni
secondari culturali rispetto a quelli
considerati primari nei luoghi di
villeggiatura frequentati della
borghesia veneziana del settecento le
gomme sono tante ma i mariti sono pochi
per quello necessario avere la più bella
la più costosa quella l'ultima moda la
nostra situazione simile
gli anni di studio e di esperienza
richiesti per l'inserimento
professionale aumentano sempre di più e
questo non perché aumentino le
competenze richieste sul mercato del
lavoro
ma perché il sistema di selezione e
sempre più competitivo i posti sono
pochi e noi siamo troppi troppi certo
cechov goldoni avevano previsto tutto ma
dietro a tutte queste mie dotte
esibizioni letterarie io vi devo
confessare che in verità e altrove che
prendo i miei riferimenti delle mie idee
da quella che è la vera cultura del
nostro tempo che sono ovviamente i memi
di internet fondamentali
avete presente solo quelle immagini
ironiche che circolano in rete
poi si trasformano mano a mano che gli
utenti se ne appropriano c'è molto
contenuto dentro per esempio il meme
reality
borst extensions che mostra l'ironia
dello stanziamento tra le alte
aspettative
vi ricordate forse il romanzo o il film
fight club racconta precisamente come
dentro ogni uomo frustrato abiti un
personaggio che ha realizzato tutte le
sue aspirazioni
l'alter ego del protagonista tyler
durden incarna tutte le caratteristiche
che vengono oggi considerate vincenti
dall'industria culturale è un
anticonformista al successo con le donne
proprio perché mette in scena a se
stesso con un rivoluzionario
prendiamo un altro man what people thing
ed un water ile du questo ci mostra come
oggi nella società
la nostra identità fascista tra quello
che crediamo di essere quello che gli
altri pensano di noi e quello che siamo
davvero se si può essere davvero qualche
cosa non esistono più delle
rappresentazioni condivise
un tempo una certa cultura con annesso
pezzo di carta era quasi meccanicamente
associata a una certa condizione
economica oggi
viviamo nel tempo della moria di classe
avete presente la disforia di genere è
la condizione di una persona che ha gli
attributi biologici o anatomici di un
sesso ma si riconosce in quello opposto
io invece di parlò di disforia di classe
quella che descrivevo all'inizio ma
questo mio sogno per descrivere la
condizione dei figli del ceto medio
cresciuti come borghesi nella loro testa
ma sempre più impoveriti nel portafogli
e questa è una forma di disordine
sociale che produce disagio che cosa ci
è successo negli ultimi dieci venti
trent'anni che cosa ci è successo se non
c'è più posto per la classe disagiata e
a causa ovviamente di uno squilibrio tra
la domanda e l'offerta sul mercato del
lavoro
ma perché ci sono così tanti aspiranti
qualche cosa che propongono delle
straordinarie competenze che in pochi
vogliono mentre nello stesso momento si
ricercano dei lavoratori meno
qualificati e lì si fanno venire
dall'altra parte del mondo perché come
vi dicevo i nostri bisogni
le nostre aspirazioni e in fondo la
nostra stessa identità sono una
costruzione sociale
noi siamo programmati per desiderare un
certo stile di vita e del proprio perché
siamo incapaci di the programmarci che
semplicemente non riusciamo ad adattare
la nostra strategia ha un mondo che
cambia vorticosamente
ci avevano detto di studiare per fare
lavori di concetto per evitare di essere
sostituiti delle macchine e ora ci
accorgiamo che non ce ne saranno
comunque abbastanza per tutte
vi cito un ultimo meme questi sono in
fondo dei fori sword problema ovvero
delle tragedie del primo mondo
certo nessuno di noi sta morendo di fame
voi siete qui potete anche permettervi
di andare a teatro
eppure emigriamo come ho fatto io ci
impoveriamo consumiamo sempre più alcol
droghe psicofarmaci e sostanzialmente ci
estinguiamo gente di 30 anni con una
fragilissima autonomia economica coppie
che invecchiano sognando il loro primo
figlio
per fortuna ci sono le famiglie il
welfare dei nonni ci ripetevamo tutti in
coro e non ci accorgevamo che proprio a
causa delle famiglie
dei loro piccoli patrimoni del loro
sostegno ci si permetteva di accertare
il salari da fame e di prolungare la
fase di inserimento nella vita attiva
partecipando a creare un drammatico
collo di bottiglia all'ingresso nel
mercato del lavoro
il problema
nella classe e disagiata non è la
povertà quella che stiamo vivendo una
crisi di sovraccumulazione come quella
che disse la repubblica di venezia al
termine del suo splendore
troppe risorse poche opportunità lo
sappiamo le risorse patrimoniali delle
famiglie italiane sono particolarmente
solida eppure quelle che scarseggiano
sono le opportunità
chi può permetterselo mobilità tutte le
sue risorse per posizionarsi sul mercato
del lavoro
siamo troppo ricchi per rinunciare alle
nostre aspirazioni e troppo poveri per
realizzarle e ognuno insegue queste
poche opportunità prendendo sempre più
tempo e denaro che forse razionale
individualmente ma è causa di un enorme
spreco collettivo di risorse
la classe disagiata e impegnata in una
tragica corsa al ribasso che si può
permettere soltanto erodendo le sue
riserve patrimoniali una guerra di
logoramento una escalation simile a
quella delle potenze atomiche
durante la guerra fredda gli stati uniti
e unione sovietica continuavano a
equipaggiarsi di armi di distruzione di
massa rendendo sempre più plausibile
l'ipotesi di una mutua distruzione
assicurata delta med la minaccia che
grava su di noi
incapaci di adottare una strategia
cooperativa è quella di un altrettanto
mutuo declassamento assicurato insomma
eccoci qua l'ordine microeconomico ha
generato disordine macroeconomico e
produce soprattutto disagio questo
terribile scarto tra aspirazioni e
realtà una bomba atomica pronta a
esplodere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]